FOLLIES WITH RAYMOND ARROYO.
BUT FIRST, TONIGHT, MASSIVE
DEVELOPMENT OR MASS HYSTERIA?
WHEN MICHAEL COYNE PLED GUILTY
TO LYING TO CONGRESS YESTERDAY,
YOU WOULD'VE THOUGHT THE
CONVERSATION MIGHT KIND OF A
CENTER ON WHAT THAT DEVELOPMENT
MEANT FOR COHEN, THE ONE WHO
ACTUALLY ADMITTED TO LYING.
INSTEAD, AS IS THEIR TRACK
RECORD, PUNDITS AND DEMOCRATS
MADE A HERCULEAN LEAP,
SUGGESTING WILD THINGS IN THE
PROCESS.
>> HE HAS A GOOD CASE FOR
COLLUSION.
IF THIS WERE A MAFIA
INVESTIGATION, TRUMP WOULD BE
INDICTED, NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
>> ON HIS FALSE STATEMENT
CHARGES, COMING CLEAN TODAY.
HE IS A MUCH MORE DANGEROUS
WITNESS.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT TO BE
NERVOUS RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE IT
APPEARS AS TIME IS RUNNING OUT.
IT HAS BECOME VERY CLEAR THAT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS IN TRYING TO
SUBVERT THE ELECTION.
>> Laura: IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE CASE?
LAST NIGHT, WE SPOKE TO SOMEONE
WHO MIGHT KNOW A THING OR TWO
ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS FORMER WHITEWATER
DEPUTY, SOL WISENBERG, WHO IS AS
HONEST AS THEY COME.
WATCH.
>> ALL >> COMEY THAT IS I L
>> ALL >> COMEY THAT IS I E
>> ALL >> COMEY THAT IS I D
>> ALL >> COMEY THAT IS I T
>> ALL >> COMEY THAT IS I O
CONGRESS, HE DIDN'T SAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HELPED ME LIVE.
THERE HE COULD BE ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT MUELLER IS KEEPING
QUIET ABOUT THAT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT COHEN HAS TOLD HIM.
THAT IS PROBLEM, BUT THAT IS
SPECULATION, LET'S TALK ABOUT
REALITY.
REALITY IS THIS IS A NOTHING
BURGER.
>> Laura: TO MAKE SENSE OF IT,
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, PROFESSOR AT
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL, AND AUTHOR
OF THE BOOK "THE CASE AGAINST
IMPEACHING TROUBLE."
>> IS A TRUMP SHAKING IN HIS BO
>> IS A TRUMP SHAKING IN HIS BT
>> IS A TRUMP SHAKING IN HIS B,
OR IS SOL RIGHT?
>> THE PRESIDENT COULD BE S
>> THE PRESIDENT COULD BE O
>> THE PRESIDENT COULD BE E
CONCERNED BECAUSE HE IS NOT
GOING TO GET A NUANCE REPORT
FROM MUELLER, MUELLER IS GOING
TO TRY TO CREATE A NARRATIVE
THAT TAKES ALL OF THE PERJURY
AND LYING CHARGES AND TRIES TO
WEAVE THEM INTO SOMETHING
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK THIS ALL SHOWS THE
EXTRAORDINARY WEAKNESS OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
IF YOU LOOK AT EVERYTHING HE HAS
COME UP WITH, THE VAST MAJORITY
OF CRIMES ARE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED AFTER HE BECAME SPECIAL
COUNSEL, NOT BEFORE.
HE WAS APPOINTED TO UNCOVER
CRIMES THAT HAVE ALREADY
OCCURRED.
INSTEAD, HE HELPED CREATE
PERJURY TRAPS, AND TRY TO FLIP
THEM AS WITNESSES.
LISTEN TO JUDGE ELLIS, WHO WAS
PRESIDING OVER THE MEDICAL CASE,
WHAT MUELLER IS DOING HE IS
TRYING TO MAKE THESE PEOPLE NOT
ONLY SANE, BUT UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES, EVEN COMPOSE.
IT DOESN'T SHOW A STRONG
PROSECUTION CASE WHEN EVERYONE
WHO HAS BEEN INDICTED IS EITHER
INDICTED FOR LYING OR INDICTED
FOR AN UNRELATED FINANCIAL
ACTIVITY THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
AT THE MOMENT, IT IS HARD TO
KNOW WHERE IS THE MEAT, THE
ACTUAL, SUBSTANTIVE CRIMES THAT
RELATE DIRECTLY TO THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA?
ALSO, WE HAVE TO ALWAYS REMIND
OURSELVES, COLLUSION IS NOT A
CRIME.
IT IS NOT A CRIME TO USE
MATERIALS STOLEN FROM ASSANGE,
TO BUILD A TOWER IN MOSCOW.
>> Laura: I WAS GOING TO GET
TO THAT.
IT WAS HILARIOUS TO ME TO WATCH
SOME OF THEM BLARING ACROSS THE
LOWER THIRD OF SCREENS ON CABLE
LAST NIGHT.
YOU MIGHT AS WELL HAVE THOUGHT
THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS CAUGHT ON
TAPE IN MOSCOW, HIGH-FIVING
PUTIN, SAYING "THANK FOR GETTING
US THOSE VOTES."
>> EVEN THAT WOULDN'T BE A CRIM
CRIME.
YOU HAVE TO FIND SOMETHING IN
THE STATUTE.
THERE ARE POLITICAL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN -- THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN DEMOCRACY AND TYRANNY.
>> Laura: WE HAVE HAD ALL OF
THESE TIDBITS OF INFORMATION
THAT HAVE TRICKLED OUT.
ALL OF THESE SO-CALLED
"BOMBSHELLS," ALAN, AND ONE
AFTER ANOTHER HAD FADED AWAY OR
BEEN COMPLETELY DISPROVEN.
BYRON YORK WROTE AN INTERESTING
PIECE TODAY, I WANT TO QUOTE
FROM IT, IT IS TITLED, HE SAYS
NOTHING ABOUT COLLUSION
ALLEGATION.
IT SAYS MUELLER SCRUTINIZE
EVERYTHING HE TOLD CONGRESS.
IF MUELLER HAD EVIDENCE OF
COHEN'S DEFINITIVE DENIAL OF THE
PRAGUE STORY, IT SEEMS
REASONABLE TO CONCLUDE THAT
MUELLER WOULD HAVE CHARGED COHEN
FOR IT.
IN THE CHARGES AGAINST COHEN,
MUELLER SAID ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
ABOUT PRAGUE.
REMEMBER THE PRAGUE MEETING?
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ANOTHER
NAIL IN THE COFFIN OF
DONALD TRUMP, AND SHOWING REAL
COLLUSION.
NO MENTION, NOTHING.
>> BUT IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND, YOU HAVE TO LOOK
FIRST AT THE STATUTE BOOKS.
YOU CAN'T LOOK TO THESE BAG,
BROUGHT STATUTE LIKE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE OR CONSPIRACY, YOU
HAVE TO FIND SPECIFIC, MENS REA,
ACT IS REAL, RESULTS.
IT SEEMS TO ME, THE MUELLER
FOUNDS, IN THEIR HASTE TO TRY TO
FIND ANYTHING ON THIS BEFORE ARE
FORGETTING BASIC LIBERTIES, AND
THAT IS THE EX POST FACTO CLAUS
CLAUSE, A SPECIFIC, CRIMINAL ACT
THAT IS ALREADY PROHIBITED BY
THE STATUTE.
THEN YOU HAVE TO PROVE IT BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT.
SO FAR AWAY FROM THAT.
>> Laura: IT SHOULD NEVER HAVE
BEEN KICKED OFF IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
IT WAS A MISTAKE FROM THE
BEGINNING, THE WAY THE LETTER
WAS WRITTEN FROM ROSENSTEIN
AUTHORIZING IT, ALL THE WAY
THROUGH TO TODAY.
YOU CALLED THIS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
OTHERS DID, AS WELL.
IT IS, ONCE AGAIN, IT IS A
CONTEST CASE AND WHY WE HAVE
REAL CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS
ABOUT THESE PROSECUTORS, WHO
HAVE A VERY LITTLE SUPERVISION.
VERY LITTLE SUPERVISION OVER
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
>> THE NEXT ISSUE IS, IS A
MUELLER GOING TO TRY TO PRODUCE
HIS REPORT AND HAVE IT MADE
PUBLIC BEFORE THE PRESIDENT'S
TEAM HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW IT, RESPOND TO IT, AND
ISSUED THEIR REPORT
SIMULTANEOUSLY?
BASIC FAIRNESS, IT ALL REQUIRES
THAT ANYTHING A PROSECUTOR
SAYS -- WHETHER AN INDICTMENT OR
A REPORT -- IS TO BE PRESUMED
TRUE.
THAT WILL UNDERCUT THE
PERCEPTION OF INNOCENCE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE TWO REPORTS
ISSUED SIMULTANEOUSLY, LET THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC JUDGE WHETHER OR
NOT THE REPORT REBUTTED AND
ANSWERED, REALLY ESTABLISHES
CRIMES, FENCES, ANY OF THE
THINGS THAT MUELLER MIGHT BE
LOOKING FOR.
I HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF SUSPICION
THAT, IN THE END, WE ARE GOING
TO SEE A LOT OF INDICTMENTS FOR
PERJURY AND LYING, A LOT OF
INDICTMENTS, BUT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO ULTIMATELY SEE ANY
CRIMES DIRECTED AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT CAN CHANGE, BUT AT THE
MOMENT, DOESN'T APPEAR THAT WAY.
>> Laura: WE WILL SEE WHATEVER
ELSE THEY MIGHT HAVE IN THEIR
QUIVER.
I WANT YOUR THOUGHTS ON ANOTHER
HUGE STORY WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME ON THIS WEEK, YOU ARE ON
RADIO EARLIER THIS WEEK, DEVOTED
AN ENTIRE SEGMENT, ALMOST TWO
SEGMENTS, TO THIS ISSUE OF
ANTI-SEMITISM RISING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE SEEN ANTI-SEMITIC ACTS
RISING IN EUROPE, AS WELL, BUT
ONE OF THE FIRST MUSLIM-AMERICAN
WOMEN ELECTED TO CONGRESS THIS
MONTH IS NOW DEFENDING THIS FIRE
TO CNN COMMENTATOR, DESPITE HIS
VICIOUSLY ANTI-ISRAEL COMMENT IN
A SPEECH HE GAVE AT THE
UNITED NATIONS.
CONGRESSMAN ELECT RASHIDA TLAIB,
TWEETED THE FOLLOWING QUOTE,
"CALLING OUT THE OPPRESSIVE
POLICIES IN ISRAEL, ADVOCATING
FOR PALESTINIANS TO HAVE PEACE
AND FREEDOM, WE ALL HAVE A RIGHT
TO SPEAK UP ABOUT INJUSTICE.
ANY AND EVERYWHERE."
WAS THAT WAS WHAT MARC LAMONT
HILL WAS DOING?
>> NO, HE WAS CALLING FOR
VIOLENCE AGAINST JEWISH
CIVILIANS.
HE WAS SAYING DON'T FOLLOW
GANDHI COME I DON'T FOLLOW
MARTIN LUTHER KING, HE WAS
PRAISING TERRORISM AGAINST
JEWISH CIVILIANS.
THERE IS NOW AN INTERNATIONAL
DEFINITION OF ANTI-SEMITISM, AND
HE FITS RIGHT IN IT.
YOU KNOW, I DEBATED HIM ON CNN,
AND HE IS A BIGOT, AND HE IS AN
ANTI-SEMITE, AND HE NEVER SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ON ANY NETWORK SHOW.
HE SHOULDN'T BE TEACHING AT A
MAJOR UNIVERSITY.
HE IS FEARLESSLY ANTI-AMERICAN
AND ANTI-SEMITIC, ANTI-ISRAEL,
AND ANTI-WESTERN VALUES IN
GENERAL.
JUST A TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE HUMAN
BEING.
SHE IS GLORIFYING VIEWS OF THAT.
>> Laura: THEY ARE STANDING BY
HIM.
THE FIRST MUSLIM-AMERICAN WOMAN
IN CONGRESS STANDING BY HIM.
>> UNIVERSITIES HAVE ACADEMIC
FREEDOM.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WHEN YOU HAVE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS STANDING BY
HIM, STANDING BY FARRAKHAN, SOME
OF THE SAME PEOPLE, HILL STOOD
BY FARRAKHAN, MANY MEMBERS OF
THE BLACK CAUCUS WHO STOOD BY
FARRAKHAN, FARRAKHAN IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST DISSEMINATORS OF
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THE COUNTRY
TODAY.
>> Laura: WHY DO THEY KEEP
DOING IT?
>> BECAUSE THEY GET AWAY WITH
IT.
BECAUSE THE FOCUS IS ON ONLY
RIGHT WING ANTI-SEMITISM, WHICH
IS CONDEMNED UNIVERSALLY.
THE SHOOTING IN PITTSBURGH?
EVERYBODY CONDEMNS IT.
BUT WHEN YOU GET ANTI-SEMITISM
COMING FROM THE HARD LEFT, LIKE
HILL AND SOME OF THESE OTHER
PEOPLE, PEOPLE DON'T CONDEMN IT,
THEY PRAY THAT, THEY STAND UP
FOR IT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE A PROFESSOR
MAKING A COMPARABLY ANTIBLACK,
OR ANTI-GAY STATEMENT?
NO UNIVERSITY WAS DOWN BY THEM.
THERE IS AN ABSOLUTE DOUBLE